tonight these 10 contestants will be
eliminated one by one using an
ever-changing set of criteria that is
never explained it's time once again for
arbitrary judgement line up let's get
started Brad you're out Zack you scored
a 4 out of 4 on what Congrats you're it
Tommy you also scored a 4 yes but your
phone was out of ten you're out Ruth
you're out why are they out
well now it's because you ask too many
questions get out Tommy rod get back in
here
you know what now that I think about it
you're both still out
Leland how many fingers am i holding up
now you're out Ruth get back out here
would you please let Tommy and Brad know
they're both still out thank you you're
out
tell me Kimmy when did you realize you
wanted to be an actress my grandmother
took me to a production of into the wood
whoo fantastic and when did you realize
that you were out was it right now
because you're out this show is so
arbitrary that even though I cut five of
you you're all still on stage and I call
your name please step forward
Tony baring Greg Eloise Tammy Paco Peter
Millicent
Norbert well played contestants none of
those names apply to any of you which
means you're in Kimmy you're out I don't
even know why you were back out here
Lance I want you to listen very
carefully to me my bologna has a first
name and it's Y oh you are II my bologna
has the second name which I don't have
time to tell you because you're out that
means it's time for the lightning round
Leland you're out Tommy you're out
please write out Britney out oh oh
[Music]
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography